So, opening is a compound operation.
So erosion and dilation are primitives.
And it's a erosion followed
by a dilation, okay?
So that's what a opening is.
And it says here, you can show
that an opening of something
of A by B is the union of all the
translations that fit entirely within A.
That's kind of complicated and wordy.
It's much easier to see in a picture.
So here's our binary thing A, and
this is our structuring element B.
And the opening is all the places,
all the translations within A,
that you can fit B.
And when you do that,
you would get out this thing here.
And you'll notice that
it has broken the,
the connection between
those two triangles.
And it's also rounded the edges.
So, it's not surprising that it's
broken them, because it's too small and
the whole thing doesn't fit there.
And the rounding is because
of the shape with B.
It says here, and, and
you know, this is a, a slide.
The opening is the area that we
can paint when the brush has
a footprint of B,
and we're not allowed to let the brush
get outside of the original image A.
One of the other cool things is,
if you take a look at this,
if I now have this shape,
I would open with B again.
Well, it fits everywhere inside of
there, so it wouldn't change, right?
That is if I kept going,
it would stay the same.
And that's referred to as idempotent,
or idempotent.
I don't know how you pronounce it.
I know how to spell it.
It's an operation that when you
repeat it, it makes no change.
So, if you erode and
then dilate, you get something.
Well if you then erode and dilate again,
you're not going to make any changes.
Which is not the same as saying if you
had erode, erode, erode, and dilate,
dilate, dilate, that, that would
be the same as erode and dilate.
So you get that?
So repeated openings,
which are erode, dilate, erode,
dilate, that doesn't
buy you anything more.
But sometimes, you want to
erode either multiple times or
with bigger shaped things,
and then, and dilate again.
So let me show you an example
of using opening for
like that cell colony thing
we were talking about.
It's a different picture,
but it's the same idea.
So, here we have this Thomas Moeslund,
thank you very much, it, in Aalborg.
So here's an original image, okay,
of some cells that are growing.
Here is a binary image, okay?
And this is the opening using
a 11 pixel disc, all right?
And you see that it pulls out,
you know, these cells pretty well.
And when you come over here,
you say okay, so it's got that one,
it's got that one, it's got that one,
it's got that one.
It's got that one, it's got that one,
it's got that one, it's got that one.
And you know, clearly,
maybe it misses this one, all right?
Maybe it misses this one.
So this tends to be common in
sort of these kinds of things.
You can find some operation which
tend to pull out what you want, but
it's not going to be perfect.
All right.